hey guys this is benny lou from new
media rockstars i'm here today with the
ceo and co and founder of karmaloop greg
selco greg how are you doing today
doing change
how you doing
good good good so yeah i'm going to go
ahead and
get right to it um so a karma loop tv is
aimed at what you call the verge culture
um what is the verge culture
so virg culture is really oh is my foot
the way you can see me okay right yeah i
can see it coach culture is the first
generation to grow up on the internet um
they're
basically multi-racial multi-ethnic
global
it's a group of people that defines
themselves less by labels and more by
shared ideas and values
um we uh you know
look at this group as a group that's
like the influencers the people who make
or break trends who have the most
fashion forward have the most disposable
income or at least the most willingness
to spend it have the newest coolest
stuff and they're basically karmaloops
customers and viewers
oh nice that's awesome uh if it's my
understanding that uh i think the
karmaloop tv um that used to actually be
um a television channel that um that was
supposed to come off the ground but it
never did um why is that
well i mean if you've noticed there
hasn't been a lot of new tv channels
lately um i think the main thing is that
tv itself is just a
in terms of you know it's not going away
tomorrow but it's kind of a stale and
shrinking industry so you're not seeing
any i mean ober trying to launch a new
tv channel and you know it didn't do
that well um you know pharrell and i
were working on this project for
three years so
now it's another year later so four
years ago tv was in a very different
place than it is now the fact is that
you know we were working with the cable
industry and the cable industry was like
look
we'll give you the tools and
freedom to do some really groundbreaking
and by the way you can do a lot of stuff
online too so it'd be like a mixture of
on and offline but the fact is they said
that but when we push came to shove we
actually started working with them they
couldn't get out of their old school
mentality so just we just decided it
wasn't worth it we pulled the plug and
now we've been doing a lot of other
stuff as you can tell can put we put our
focus online right right right um so you
so you're definitely like a big
supporter of like the whole new media
movement and uh this like uh this influx
of like online video platforms uh that
are out there at the moment like that's
something that you have basically like
you know
the spotting of a new era and uh you
know all it's going to take is one uh
major channel like an hbo to say what
the [ __ ] do i need cable for i'm going
to just go direct to the consumer
meaning you can just get it on the tv
you can stream it on the tv or on your
ipad without having a cable subscription
because now you can do that but you need
to go through a cable provider as soon
as they do that they're going to break
the choke hold of the cable industry on
on this and then everyone will go direct
what i mean in reality what do any of
these channels need tv for
what do they need the cable companies
for it's just it's just how it's always
been done
um but it's not going to last that much
longer right well um there was actually
an interview that was done with uh time
warner's ceo and he he kind of like
belittled like the new media industry in
a sense so i guess the direct question
that he was asked was uh you know do you
do you think that uh these companies
like netflix and youtube are they a big
uh
competitor are they big competitors to
uh to time warner and then he kind of
said well just to put everything into
perspective like you have youtube
boasting about uh investing 100 million
dollars into their channel well just to
let you know we spent five billion
dollars uh last year alone in uh
producing content so um welcome kind of
yeah yeah well i think i would when i
would say that
what else is he gonna say he's he's
you know being on the defensive i would
say this
cable's not even close to debt right now
and there's still
you know
millions and millions and millions of
households with cable in them
but the fact is that it's one of those
things where
it doesn't it it's like moore's law it's
going to continue to rapidly increase
and at one point it's going to hit the
tipping point and all of a sudden the
cable cut group is going to see their
subscriptions plummet right now
there's uh first uh their their their
subscribers are
definitely going down
but the rates gonna continue to increase
as there's better better offerings
online um
so yeah in the short run he's right but
you know
everything starts someplace and you know
how many times the
radio said the same thing about tv tv
said the same thing about your cable
cables saying the same thing about the
internet well the fact is that
you know they're on the wrong side of
history if they think that uh they can
continue the same model that they do now
and have it last forever because
what is a cable operator a cable
operator someone that aggregates
content and says hey it's vetted this is
good content you guys are going to want
to watch you pay us a subscription and
we deliver it to your house
in theory all those people who are
delivering content now could deliver
that same content to the tv over the
internet the problem is it's not
it's not well packaged yet there's still
issues with streaming there's some
technological technical technology lag
but the fact is
we're talking two three years before you
can get the exact same quality and
experience and so someone else is going
to come along as
just like netflix is doing with uh
arrested development and start
developing content people want to see as
much as they want to see hbo hbo is
[ __ ] awesome they make great content
better than anyone on or offline if hbo
went direct and i'm sure they want to at
some point but they have they have
contracts that last four five six years
with these cable operators
it takes one guy to it's like you know
it's like uh it's anything when you see
like you even look at like the arab
spring and what happened you know first
everyone to help no one can no one can
uh gaddafi's
the dictator you know he's no one's ever
gonna leave him one guy leaves one guy
leaves i said it's crazy it's just one
guy then two guys two of his guys defect
third guy comes the united states the
the uh
then the head of the armed forces holy
[ __ ] that's a big blow then all of a
sudden you lose half the country then he
lose two thirds of the country and all
of a sudden this guy was invincible two
years ago you know being [ __ ] beaten
to death in the in the desert right
so
it's going to be the same you know i'm
not calling the cable industry dictators
but there's definitely some similarities
not necessarily the violence but
certainly the way they dominate and
control everything at some point
it's just gonna take one person and the
next the next and then everyone's gonna
say [ __ ] you what do we need you for
right because
because the thing is right now the
advantage that they have the cable
industry is up is that on the internet
there's so much choice right there's so
much choice so there's not enough
critical mass
behind one or two shows you need to get
a couple really big hit shows that have
the equivalent of like a
prime time like uh the office or
or 30 rock where you have a whole group
of a whole demographic people watch it
and they watch it online instead of it's
not on and i think arrested
development's one that could be like
that right where it becomes a show a tv
show that people talk about at work and
stuff that millions and millions and
millions of same people watch it's a
half hour long it's not because right
now what youtube mostly is they may have
a huge amount of viewers but it's mostly
like people's
cats and people falling down stairs and
you know some of these upstart like the
hall girls reviewing uh
products and stuff there's not a real
traditional
tv kind of model with like a half hour
entertainment show comedy sitcom things
like that those models still work but as
more and more of those things come
around and as some of the people who
create them now say we don't need why do
we need to go through a middleman and
pay him all this money it will
eventually happen um and i think you
have people like myspace are going to
try and launch this tv
platform that's going to be
the other problem has been the
compatibility of getting it into the
flat screen the large flat screen tv
that's changing every every new model
comes out makes it more and more
internet compatible so that's the other
advantage cable had even though
it's still the internet is like
you know sensory overload as they figure
out ways to repackage it in more bite
size and understand i think what album
tv has done is great um
i think there's going to be some need
for
also to have you know
linear programming too where it's like
you can watch things on demand but
people do like to be like hey what's on
right now you know and i think i think
that you know one of the things that
karmalit's doing is like we experimented
with this
uh you know we did cyber cam monday i
don't know if you saw what we did but we
basically had a live stream for 24 hours
on cyber monday where we had like
cyber cam girls and we had like it was
basically like a parody of like
sex cams but we gave away like instead
of you know being about just girls
taking up their clothes and we were
giving away tons of like
gift certificates and doing contests and
all this stuff people really liked the
live aspect or the the fact that it was
like a thing you tuned into to see what
happened and we're doing it again this
monday so uh we're doing the freakathon
this monday we have people like bunbee
and travie mccoy we're doing a live you
know uh 14-hour broadcast where we're
gonna do just it's like almost like a
variety show where we're giving away
gift certificates and just doing crazy
[ __ ] and they'll be
you know it'll be over the top again but
i mean we had a massive success with
that
awesome that's great that was a hell of
an answer by the way
yeah
that's awesome all right well great
afternoon coffee yet
well all right great yeah you pretty
much answered most of the questions i
have for uh content online versus
traditional so um yeah i'd like to move
on to um you know talking about when you
first started karmaloop and so um you
know when you were building karmaloop
out of your parents basement did you
envision it as the massive success that
it has become now or were your dreams
quite modest at the time
well i mean i think the the
uh i didn't envision what it would be to
this extent but i mean i always looked
at it as sort of a media property and
first of all my first business plan said
karma was more than a retailer or a
community of style or full-fledged media
property and so i always looked at the
internet as media right so
you can sell clothes but you can also
tell stories around the clothes
particularly the type of clothing we
sell there's so much to it the
celebrities the skaters the djs the
other people the the designers what the
brands mean the cultural references all
that [ __ ] so it made a ton of sense so i
always wanted it to be something more
than just you know
like you just put the stuff up and it's
like a catalog and it sells
um and i i'm the type of person who
always tries to go big when i do stuff i
don't try to do i'm not all i'm all i'm
i always want more i always want to push
the envelope more so the answer is i
didn't know what it would become but i
certainly wasn't trying to do something
small like i was trying to do something
big and groundbreaking and i think we've
done a lot of things at groundbreaking
with the fact we've made this media
commerce and content hybrid you go to
carmeltv.com right now we have these
gift guides which are clickable tv um so
that you can there's product in the in
the videos and you can click and buy on
it and that's been talked about for so
long but we actually do it and it's
effective it works people are buying
stuff through video and it's not just
video like hey show the product it's
entertainment oh but by the way you can
buy [ __ ] while you're watching
wow i love it
okay cool um uh you're relatively uh
transparent when it comes to um you know
your public opinions and everything so
for example um you supported obama
publicly in the last election um do you
ever worry that your political stances
would hurt your business at all
yeah i mean i don't i i don't know i
don't worry
about it i i i know that that's a
concern and and you know i have
investors with other people they're not
always that comfortable but they
invested in me so they you know what
they
signed up and i think the thing that's
made karmaloop successful is our
authenticity and you know our our our
you know i have my personal cell phone
number on the website that's my real
number people can really call me um and
you know
uh i had it very clear if someone calls
me like hey i want to sell you this
software or sell you my clothing brand i
don't respond but that's always there
but i want to talk to you if they're
customers or they just want to talk
about things they have ideas i mean i
talk to people all the time every day i
talk to people just call me up so so
yeah we try to be very transparent
um i mean the fortunate thing is that
the mark demographic that we're selling
clothing to eighteen to thirty five
hundred roles speech about 1825
overwhelmingly supported obama anyways
in the election so
we have relatively we got some
complaints from parents and stuff and we
have some people like why are you doing
this like why don't you just stay
neutral and stuff and i was like no
one's neutral every business
and most of them are supporting the
republicans is involved they just don't
have the balls to just say let's say the
truth but they're funneling million
dollars to the republican candidates i
don't have that kind of money um so i i
did what i could help by just saying
this is what i believe and you know i
got some debates just
about twitter and i said look
if you don't want to buy from us anymore
because of my political opinion i
respect that i don't want that to be the
case i hope you stay but i'm not going
to hide how i believe and hopefully we
don't have to be like everyone in
washington dc where they disagree and
they want to [ __ ] stab each other in
the eye it's like look
i everyone in their family has some
people who have different political
uh opinions i have republicans in my
family um i know it's hard to believe
not many but distant relatives but the
fact is that you can you don't have to
it doesn't have to get to the point
where like the tea party or the occupy
movement where you're so polarized that
you can't like like anything or have
anything to do with someone else because
they have a different political opinion
and i think when i when i hit people up
and who were kind of [ __ ] at me and i
had a a real discussion and gave my
opinions to look i i respect your
opinion but i disagree well i'm really
all alright cool i forgive you kind of
thing right right right um you mentioned
that you said yeah their cell phone
number like on the website um how many
calls do you get like a day
if you don't want me asking
well it depends i mean
many of the emails that we sent out we
have a two and a half million person
email list my cell phone numbers in that
too when i write a personal letter my
cell phone's at the bottom of it um i
would say i get
anywhere from two to twenty calls a day
that's actually that's quite modest
actually for the for the for the amount
of uh
uh for like how transparent it is like
like it's everywhere
yeah i mean i i think it's uh
you know i think it's more that people
appreciate and know that they can get in
touch with me i mean a lot of the calls
are like hey what's up uh and i'm like
hello and they're like hey
uh i'm like yes can i help you oh i just
wanna see if this is your real number
buy and hang up a lot of times it's just
people testing out to see if it's real i
mean that's like a 50 of them um and
then you know
but i mean i i chat with people and dude
i have right now i can barely move my
hands because i i text so much with
customers i mean i'm a lot of people
hitting me up with like oh this is an
issue
uh you know not not basic customer
service well they'll be like hey you
know i think it's in general you should
do this or that i think that's one of
the reasons why we've been successful is
i actually engage with our audience and
know and can hear
what they think and what they what they
think you know we should be doing
right right right that's crazy and you
and you answer all of them like yourself
you don't have like an assistant or
anything like every single one text is
sent
yeah i answer myself no one else has my
phone
right um
there's a lot of people i don't answer
though because
it's very clear that i made it very
clear that if you're like hey i want to
sell my brand and karma what do i hook
me up or give me a gift code or
uh you know i a lot of people like i'm
from so and so software company and i
know you said not to call but my product
is so good that
and so that's not the purpose of the
they can call the right right people and
sometimes i'll
especially the clothing brands i'll just
pass them on to the right person but you
know i'm here i'm here for the customers
that's what i'm supposed that that's
that's what my customers and people who
want to talk about improving the site or
how or you know give me feedback that's
that's what that's what it's there for
us so the people who pitch me on on
on solicit me on business stuff and they
just don't hear from me i don't always
pick it up a lot of times i'll let it go
to voicemail and i'll listen to it and
get back but i mean certainly i'll pick
up my phone too when a customer calls
many times
okay
great um you know speaking of which um
uh karmaloop is obviously a very
successful like internet business um and
you know you've definitely succeeded in
uh uh building that and so um what would
you say are the components for anyone
that's trying to build um a successful
internet business themselves whether as
an artist or you know as uh you know as
a business trying to sell a product or
what have you
um
i would say that first of all have a
good idea
one of the things that i see when i see
a lot of
good and original ideas when i see
people who pitch me on clothing brands
or new brands they look like someone
else's brand so one brand pioneer or
something then they'll copy it new brand
comes on pioneer so i think you need to
have something that's original that's
different
um that's that's the first thing the
second thing is you have to have
unshakable belief in your idea
right if you have any doubt um
you know if you have any doubt uh
in in and then
you know
obviously there's the natural like i
tell myself every day or i'm nervous or
whatever but if at the core
uh you could be worried that doesn't
mean you're just like you're not you're
not like just cruising like oh i know
but you got to really believe you can
make something work and if you do then
you got to be ready to hear a lot of bad
things said i mean people say terrible
things on the internet about me about
the company about you know stuff that's
total nonsense most of the time it's a
competitor or whatever but you got to
just have a thick skin you got to be
able to you know
know that you can handle criticism where
people say i want to invest in your idea
your idea sucks or it's not going to
it's just it's the nature of the game
and you can't you can't get discouraged
because i had so many people shots
some literally and mostly figuratively
basically slam the door in my face like
dude you know shit's never going to work
basically laughing your face so
if you can't handle that don't don't
don't try because you got to be willing
to be able to pick yourself up over and
over again um
so i mean i think the thing you have
something great and then you're not
willing to quit i'm not willing to take
no for an answer
awesome i love it
um
uh you know your street team is like you
know great marketing i mean like how
many i think you guys have i don't even
know how many reps you have like almost
40 000 reps yeah you guys have a ton of
reps i mean what do you think makes it
so successful
well i mean i think
one of the things that like when i'm at
if i'm speaking at conferences
and stuff like that is like
um you know we get a lot of people like
oh i want to create a you know i read
about your rep team and new york times
or whatever we want to create the same
thing and i'm like what do you sell like
oh we sell like uh
you know uh
toothpaste or something like that and
i'm like look
i mean
try it if you can but toothpaste doesn't
really get people that excited or
motivated so the
the fact is the rep program only works
with people like us and there's not a
huge amount of people left because the
kids who wrap us are people who live and
breathe the culture every day it's more
than just about the clothing it's about
who they are as a person expressing
themselves um and and being into a
culture being into a fashion or whatever
and so they want to be part of from the
commonwealth family so
that's why it works so i don't think
that
you know there's a lot of people who you
know i don't think you'd get the same
passion if it was walmart you know
right right right um do you see yourself
like branching out and uh like how long
do you see yourself doing karmaloop
right now like do you have any other
passions in terms of like starting other
businesses or ventures in the long run
i mean i i hope i can you know i was
thinking about that the other day like
yesterday i was actually like walking to
work and it's [ __ ] really stressful
right now because it's christmas and we
have big numbers we need to hit and i
was like i just hope this never ends
though because
it's just you know i'll be sad to
to
to not be doing caramel because it's
it's so it's it's it's so much fun and
like
but it's a lot of work people don't
understand like we have we had a meeting
in this very room this morning we're all
yelling at each other all this you know
lively debates we all everyone loves
each other and it's a great team
it's like come to work where there's
dogs everywhere there's a lot of like
young people who are passionate it's
just a great thing so i don't wanna i
don't see myself doing anything now i
mean yeah will i ever do something else
probably um i think the next thing i do
would be something to do with like
non-profit type stuff
okay yeah and i'm gonna touch on your
non-profit uh at the end of this uh at
the end of this thing uh but um
to for back to karmaloop um do you ever
plan to open another physical retail
storefront um for it
the physical storefront was fun
we lost money every year
it was like a zoo
we had a lot of parties and events and
it was good for our image but you know
we weren't running it like a business so
um
i don't have any plans in the short run
but if i if i partnered up with someone
who knew what they were doing because i
certainly don't know what i'm doing when
it comes to bricks and mortar retail my
expertise is here online um i would
consider it but no it's not it's not
definitely there's nothing in the works
right now okay uh what are your thoughts
on uh on your company possibly going
public next year
i mean you know we'll see what happens
there's been a lot of pressure on us to
go public which is a good thing which
means that
in fact we've gotten even calls from one
of the stock exchanges i won't say which
one was like hey we want you to go
public we think it'll be a great
offering on our exchange uh you know we
just think the brand sexy as good
so you know i think the
possibility of going public is
the coolest thing about it would be that
all our customers would get to own a
piece of the company to me that's cool
um but i think the the you know
we don't have any we're not like
preparing right now to go public it
takes a year to prepare so we haven't
started doing anything like that so who
knows what will happen we may take on
like a new investor that can help us do
some stuff but i i don't know you know
we don't have to do anything because the
company's doing great um privately but
you know we'll look at everything
okay
right on
um so uh my last question is uh you know
about your non-profit ventures so you
just launch a nonprofit the future
boston alliance um you know tell me a
little bit more about that
so you know karma moves here in boston
um
boston's not necessarily traditionally
been a hotbed of uh fashion that's for
sure
but there's a lot of cool things going
on here i mean there's wayfair uh rue la
la karmaloo then there's a ton of text
on startups uh
you know a ton of different uh you know
entrepreneurial businesses and stuff we
obviously have tons of kids who come
here for college um and so the concept
was that like look i have 250 employees
in boston we also have an office in new
york with 35 people but the most of
everything happens here and like there's
a lot of like things about boston that
are still very old-fashioned in terms of
like uh you know it's hard to get food
late at night taxis are like a pain in
that we don't have enough taxis the
subway system shuts down at [ __ ] 12
30 which is the earliest in the country
where are you guys
uh we're in uh los angeles that's it
well you don't care about subways there
oh you're stuck
you're starting to have you're starting
to get
puts them in which is cool i think yeah
downtown l.a is definitely popping off
but i mean there's a lot of i mean
your bars closer too or where it's
closer too so it's not it's not really
about but then there's i mean there's a
lot more to it there's tons of [ __ ]
red tape when you try to open a new
place so you don't get us enough new
vibrant places and our whole thesis
behind it is like look if you want
boston to be the startup hub which they
talk about in city hall
you can't have a city that's not
attractive to young hip entrepreneurial
types of people that might work at
carmelo so um
and plus we want to have a better art
scene and support culture and support
you know different club sites and stuff
to make it more just a more fun city
that i want to live in
so instead of complaining like everyone
did i said let's start an organization
so we started something called the
future boston alliance um and it's been
like super successful uh we've gotten
thousands of people that it obviously
hit a nerve the mayor hates our guts
because we've been we're the only people
who've been have enough balls to
criticize him and say look part of the
problem is with him and he hasn't he
doesn't get a nightlife or
young people's issues as a major
economic development thing and instead
of listening to us of course he
um boston is an interesting place we've
got the same mayor since i uh i was in
high school
so
um and there's no term limits the guy
just and very few people vote in the
local elections and so and he's created
a thing where he you know he really
punishes any business that speaks out
against if it's a restaurant or whatever
can't really do anything to us because
we're online so it gives us a unique
position and i've been very vocal um it
would be smarter for him just to listen
but you know he didn't and in fact it
was tons and tons of press where we were
going back and forth in the press and it
was pretty cool that we were elevated to
the point where we were getting equal
voice where you know we had we had lots
of people coming to our events we do a
weekly uh club like a weekly like night
at a bar where we have a repair artist
for the start business and future bus
alliance and we just have a night with
different d local djs and [ __ ] we've
been getting a lot a lot of uh
accolades we've been using new media we
made a really funny video i don't know
if you saw the video um uh on youtube
which has gotten i think it's like 30
000 views at this point where we just
talk about the issues if you haven't
seen it you should check it out okay
we can uh uh just search future boston
alliance and it will come out uh do you
know what what's the youtube channel
name
uh so we we're we don't have a channel
per se i think it's on uh but we have uh
because we only have a few youtube
videos so most of if you go to
futureboston.com
that's where the video is hosted there
too we just use youtube as a player but
it's if you can find it on its own on
youtube as well
but future boston.com is our website
okay it's a video it has all sorts of
information on on the nonprofit okay
great um is there do you have any last
words or anything that um you know you
want to say or any exciting things
happening with karmaloop in the next few
months that you want to reveal
well i mean i don't know when this is
airing but obviously you watch monday on
karma we're going live it's going to be
madness we'll be giving away products
it'll be entertainment
bunbee travis mccoy a bunch of different
celebrities are coming on
um to host um
you know we're going to be doing more
live events carmen tv
uh you know we're continuing to expand
there we're going to be hopefully
launching a regular series uh called
girl hatton which is an original product
like sitcom like production that we shot
that will be launching in 2013. um
so i mean we've got a ton of stuff going
on the site continues to grow we have
carmelo we have bookplunder.com which is
our off price site plndr.com we have
brick harbor which is our skate site we
have miss kl which is our women's site
miss kl.com and then we have boylston
training which is like a little bit
higher in men's side so we've got a ton
of stuff coming up coming up
we keep appreciate the support from
everyone you know we'll be keep pushing
the envelope and doing things
differently cool well thank you for
speaking with me today and uh you know i
wish you the best of luck with
everything and congratulate and
congratulations on all your success
thanks a lot appreciate it all right